okay if we have this if statement here
right it's a super super simple one all
they can handle is one condition going
one way or another okay but in reality
as you guys know on this kind of like
BMI and then there's ranges it must be
like four or five or something like that
they like you know one to ten probably
you know dead you know eleven to twenty
eight you know really underway you get
the idea right so so it's more than just
there's a magic number and if you're
above or below your this or that so how
do we get our if statement to actually
do that to have a more complicated
statement and the way you do it the
simplest way is to what we call the nest
the statements you know called nested
statements okay so here's the idea let's
start this one again okay let's say look
this is the seller interests into f2
it's the one which classifies you and
says you're this kind of person right we
do need an if statement let's say it
okay let's go above twenty five again
just for the sake of simplicity so if
the BMI is greater than 25 okay let's
say alright I think lose weight so let's
call that every way okay now so far the
same okay where it starts to change is
the next bit okay so the third party's
well what happens if this condition is
not met okay so what I'm gonna do is
rather than just have one outcome namely
underweight okay I'm gonna have another
pair of outcomes okay I wanted to branch
off again okay so to make a branch off
I'm gonna do exactly the same thing I
did in the first place this is how I
made things branch off by using an if
statement so I'll just put another if
statement and nestled inside the other
one okay that's why they called nested
statements so I'm gonna say after this
comma we're gonna say if all over again
okay
so now let's go with this okay let's
let's say if you're between one to ten
right you shouldn't be alive right now
so let's consider if the BMI is less
than ten is less than ten okay now what
should I say suppose the BMI was
something like say five okay well we
want to say well dude how are you even
feeling this fall about okay so that's
my outcome if this is true that alright
if it's not sure if it's not less than
ten I already know that it's got to be
less than twenty five right so it's
greater than ten less than 25 right cuz
this one wasn't met and neither was this
okay so now I've got this range I'm ten
to twenty five okay does that make sense
that time I got a third option so I'll
say I'll say you know normal because
you're either overweight normal or dead
that's the way things hi okay right so
now that I finished this if statement
which is on its own I have to finish the
big if statement which started over here
so I end it really another parenthesis
okay so let's just match through this
and test it out okay suppose my BMI came
out at 30 right so what happens if BMI
is Grande 25 what happens it's dirty so
it checks out so this is what happens
that's what gets displayed okay let's
try again suppose the BMI is 20 okay so
come over here is it greater than 25 not
so I skip this part because this is the
value if it's true and now I come to
this right so then I start over there
again I'm 20 right is that value less
than 10 no so it skips this goes there
some normal lastly I've got a BMI of 5
which I almost look like I do I get to
here it's it's false so I skip this ok I
get to here and it's true because 5 is
less than 10 so it says that
unfortunately it's going
okay do you see how it's taking one at a
time now what if we wanted more than
three what if you wanted for all I guess
you could do it again but in reality
this is about as complicated as it gets
because if if as a markup right as an
exam setup rather I wanted to test your
ability to understand the way these
statements work
I don't gain anything about seeing your
understanding of spreadsheets by putting
another one in because it's just the
same thing all over again just longer
and more tiresome okay so all the logic
and the things that I'm testing for I'm
visible here and that's how you would
get a third option